alors très concrètement déjà j'ai fait
le choix effectivement de ne pas me
faire vacciner alors je suis vacciné un
toutes les vaccinations sont qui sont
obligatoires bien sûr je suis à jour
c'est évident que c'est important que
c'est un enjeu de santé publique par
contre cette vaccination là qu'on
m'impose sans avoir rassuré sur sur son
fondement deçà je suis contre
je me suis informé beaucoup puisque
personne n'a pu me donner d'information
transparente on a cherché on a recoupé
les données on s'est aperçu quand même
qu'il y avait des choses qui étaient tus
en terme par exemple
d'accidents vaccinaux on a regardé un
peu les cours d'incidents sont à
regarder notamment est-ce que je suis
une personne à risque est ce que j'ai un
bénéfice ou pas à me faire vacciner
est-ce que j'ai plus de risques donc
avant de prendre cette décision là il a
fallu beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
parce qu'on n'a pas pu vraiment compter
ni sur le corps scientifique vous avez
plus
pernicieux encore politiques dont vous
avez plus peur du vaccin que du virus en
fait alors c'est surtout que jusque là
je ne fais pas partie des personnes à
risque donc comment sont peut-être par
finir de vacciner les personnes à risque
et moi je peux prendre des décisions
pour moi j'ai justement fait un travail
de recherche puisque je n'ai pas eu des
accès aux informations il a fallu que
moi je m'informe oui mais que va-t-il se
passer pour vous ou professionnellement
ce que la caution pouvoir décider en
tant que patient ça s'appelle le libre
choix éclairé donc j'ai fait le choix de
ne pas me faire vacciner d'accord mais
ma question était de savoir les
constructions sur ses clients que ça
aurait donc du coup en tant que
soignante je suis obligé à partir du 15
septembre de présenter au moins la
première vaccination
vous n'avez pas l'intention de le faire
je suis là pour être présente auprès des
patients c'est ma vocation comme tous
mes collègues par ailleurs je ne peux
pas me faire injecter quelque chose qui
me fait peur d'accord parce que il n'a
pas fait ses preuves je reviens à la
question qu'est ce qui va se passer
professionnellement et bien c'est que je
risque la mise à pied d'accord je ne
pourrais plus travailler je ne pourrai
plus le roi que mes enfants je ne
pourrai plus payer mes charges
voilà ce qui va se passer il faut être
sacrément convaincu pour tenir cette
position là et je vous assure qu'il y en
a un paquet à l'hôpital qui sont sûr de
ça parce que nous on voit aussi la
deuxième vague de patients qui ont déjà
été si vous étiez très très courageuse
reviennent malgré tout ils ont été
vaccinés ils reviennent parce qu'en fait
finalement le problème on est bien
d'accord c'est les comorbidités mais
c'est quand même très étrange et récuse
moi parce qu'on parle de courage c'est
quand même très étrange de placer le
courage dans le dimension sociale où on
sait finalement qu'en france on risque
pas grand chose et de ne pas placer le
courage dans sa dimension première
c'est-à-dire le courage physique et je
suis très étonné de ce raisonnement et
c'est vrai que l'on peut pas mettre dans
la balance la couette une piqûre de
vendin beaucoup encourage le problème
c'est effectivement quelle est cette
injection là oui ça mais ça qui est
important
besoin de garanties là où on n'a pas les
garanties la hausse s'est donné
totalement d'or à madame c'est
qu'effectivement il ya d'un côté un
inconnu qui celui du vaccin admettons et
un inconnu qui est celui du virus sauf
que l'inconnu du vaccin ont choisi ou
pas de souligner qu les alors que
l'inconnu de virus par définition et
c'est lui qui nous choisit pas l'
inverse alors le biais de cdo est
surtout plus confiance à ses côtés un
chercheur
combats la vie alors il faudrait des
faut tout arrêter c'est la fin du monde
car combien sont jeunes quand même dont
c'est le métier et funk faire confirmer
fermture certainement je reformule la
question si quelqu'un du personnel
soignant n'a pas confiance dans la
médecine est ce que vous rendez bien
compte de l'effet ravageur que ça sur
l'ensemble de la population alors on
parle de quoi on parle de l'injection où
on parle du virus à du mépris est quand
même important c'est qu'elles vont être
les effets secondaires du vaccin on est
très très proche finalement on est
encore dans une phase d'expérimentation
actuellement
en attendant on est encore dans une
phase d'expérimentation et justement les
études sont en cours et on s'aperçoit
effectivement des effets secondaires des
risques à long terme à moyen terme et un
instant on a plus de risque à être
vaccinés kanpai d'auxigny selon vous
alors ça c'est une très bonne question
on n'a pas le recul donc c'est compliqué
quand même de vacciner deux forces un
certain nombre de gens sans pouvoir leur
garantir qu'ils ne mettent pas leur
santé en jeu
qu'est-ce qu'elle qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous laissons vivre comme on a un
vécu pendant un an c'est tout est fermé
déjà je suis sheed parce qu'ils perdent
leur entreprise on y passe à ces jeunes
là on pas aussi alors moi ce que je veux
moi ce que je veux c'est pouvoir décider
en toute connaissance vous pouvez puis
ma santé mais vous pouvez décider de ne
pas vous avez brûlé a donc madame aéré
et bien n'allez pas perdre votre emploi
là c'est ce que je voulais me venger
comme ce temps je vais vous rassurer
parce que nous avons voté et j'étais
donc je peux vous dire que nous avons
voté que justement les gens qui
choisissent ne pas vacciner dans 15
aides soignants ne seront pas licenciés
ils seront mises à pied vous l'avait dit
pour une réaffectation dans une zone où
ils ne seront plus soignants dont vous
faites un choix mais vous ne perdrez pas
votre emploi je vais beaucoup rester un
peu
il faut pas faire croire aux gens que
les gens soignants qui ne refusons la
valorisation seront mises à pied ou
licenciés d'accord on allait chercher
une touche en importance à
s'accroître relatif mais absolument de
ce fait vous pourrez ouvrir mon corps va
pas de problème d'accord qu'il faut pas
non mais madame moi je respecte votre
choix et là on l'a dit je ne vous mets
police pas certainement pas gêner les
soignants le droit de travailler parce
qu'ils ont une technicité non non
vous aiderez la russie réussit et de
chercheurs vous êtes déjà vaccinées de
quatre maladies principales vous le
savez c'est obligatoire pour pratiquer
vous avez une autre obligation il ya
plein de métiers où on allait
changer de métier